Ramona shelburne ESPN NBA insiders
senior writer and had a deep dive into
what happened last Wednesday night with
Oklahoma City and Utah and kind enough
to join us to talk about that
good morning Ramona and how will Rudy
Gobert be remembered when it comes to
this you know Dan I think the term we're
all looking for a useful idiot right you
know when when you look back on on on
that moment it got it feels like a long
time ago doesn't it like because so much
has happened since that and it was
really just last week but you know that
we I remember that morning Rudy Gobert
was you know we started the hearing oh
yeah Rudy Gobert I was an illness couple
days after he had that press conference
where he was licking everyone's
microphones and everybody was like yeah
that's like one of those things that
goes around on social media like you
didn't think I was like a real thing I
wonder if he has the coronavirus right I
mean it was it was literally like that
level of it felt like a joke and it was
obviously true and I think what was so
incredible for me and just reporting on
this it piecing together the timeline of
everything was you know how there was a
small handful of people who knew
Wednesday morning that Rudy Gobert was
being tested for Kovac 19 and that group
included you know Utah the Utah Jazz
their trainers the people you know some
people in the league office and county
has a County health officials in
Oklahoma City but the NBA Board of
Governors was having the conference call
that day talking about scenarios and
best case worst case scenarios etc and
they couldn't know that because their
federal privacy laws right so they had
to be debating these things in their own
in their own time and at that time it
still felt like a lot to be cancelling
fans at games hey I mean I mean we were
still talking about the the you know is
there a way it gradually ease into the
social distancing is there a way to keep
playing the games
and you know that just limit the number
of people here yeah and you know I can
only imagine the NBA officials on the
phone having this conversation
letting the owners have their say
everybody coming to their own level of
acceptance with this while in the back
of their minds knowing well you know for
Rigoberta test comes back positive oil
shut down anyway and that's exactly what
happened if you're always later what if
he didn't test positive but I think
that's the question I don't think they
would shut down I yeah the plan was
after that Board of Governors meeting
everyone was gonna sleep on it there the
president was going to give an address
that night so I think a lot of owners
wanted to see what he was going to say
first but the plan was rad silver to
basically say okay no more fan thinking
in the morning I think that's what what
happened if Gobert would have tested
negative and yeah you know like we
evolved in you know that all the experts
say the sooner you do this the better
and so I think that's where I keep
coming up with that useful idiot term
right I mean it's just you know he was
he's since apologized for being so
cavalier about this or joking around
about it but but he may have saved a lot
of lives because we would probably still
be playing games and exposing a lot of
people yeah I calling me inadvertent
hero because I think there's he's he's
going down in history he'll be mentioned
when it comes to this virus you know
good or bad we're talking to Ramona
Shelburne ESPN NBA insiders senior
writer what options do you think the NBA
is going to have if they resume
basketball let's say in mid-june yeah I
don't see a world in which we picked
that regular season back up it just
doesn't you know why would you try to
cram in the last you know ten games of
the year or something it is where it
doesn't it doesn't feel like important
right now to even be thinking about that
I can see a world that we have a
playoffs whether at the full playoffs or
a limited playoffs I'm not sure I think
everybody would like to have some
conclusion to the season whether that
takes place in June July
yes that would be that would be good but
I don't know you know the the one thing
you know I was over keep saying is the
more the the best experts that you talk
to they've been consulting with you know
just the best experts right I saw dr.
David Howe he's he's one of the
groundbreaking doctors on the on HIV and
AIDS right he's he's now one of the lead
doctors trying to find the vaccine for
corona virus and treatment options right
the NBA has been consulting with him
because he's they've known him since
United Johnson days right when they when
they had to deal in HIV and try to
understand the signs that they like the
best experts in the world the one thing
that they continue to say to everyone or
and and especially the NBA is there's so
much about this that we don't know and
so like to say that I think we're going
to be back in June I don't know you know
when this when the league shut down I
thought we'd be back in May no I was in
late June yeah it was a great read Ramon
he did a wonderful job recapping that in
real time you know the timeline of what
happened last Wednesday that'll be part
of NBA history we appreciate you joining
us that's Ramona Shelburne yes be an NBA
insider senior writer